good afternoon and thank you so much for
joining us on this monday at 4 o'clock
i'm kirsten joyce good afternoon i'm
brian loftis the number of nevadans
diagnosed with covid does continue to
climb
we begin with a look at those numbers
here's the latest
today's report showing our state with
more than
sixteen hundred new cases and eight
deaths we've seen that number sit
at over one thousand for almost thirty
days now since march there have been
more than a hundred fifty two thousand
cases
and twenty one hundred deaths now here
in the county we claim about 1100 of
those new daily cases
four new deaths were also reported today
the recovery rate
there at the bottom of your tv sits at
84.8 percent
with those rising numbers hospitals are
getting closer to full and it will take
weeks to learn
the impact that thanksgiving weekend and
all that travel
will have on our hospitals the i-team's
vanessa murphy monitoring the numbers
she joins us live from her home studio
to tell us what health officials are
saying
about the uptick in cases
yeah brian we are seeing record-breaking
numbers here remember that spike in july
and hospitals were strained
the numbers are worse now and they
continue
to climb test positivity rate is over 17
this is the highest since the start of
the pandemic
it's considered too high at even 5
hospitalizations are at a record high in
a call with the state's covet 19
response director caleb cage
he points to a 275 percent
increase in hospitalizations over the
last 30 days in southern nevada and a
surge
is expected according to the federal and
state health officials
with current growth rates and case rate
and several factors such as colder
weather leading to more indoor
activities
and back-to-back holidays numbers are
likely to surge
in the coming weeks
we will not know how thanksgiving day
and the long weekend helped spread the
virus even more because
there is that possible 14-day incubation
period
meaning if someone gets tested today
after being exposed to the virus on
thanksgiving and the test comes back
negative they can still test positive
up to 14 days after now the stay at home
pause issued by governor steve
sissellach began
last tuesday it's three weeks long the
governor has said he wants to avoid
another shutdown
especially in a state like nevada
because we rely so heavily on tourism
but if the numbers continue to go up we
could see
additional restrictions reporting live
vanessa murphy 8 news now